you
uh Louis uh Wow um well um hmm okay well
Louis this is um rather sudden don't you
think what exactly are you doing in my
apartment Louis well we did have
something to do and I didn't know we
were going to work on a report a news
report that is platonic and entirely
platonic but I'm not like Harry's when I
care now easy he's got better things to
report on swear I hear I'm gonna talk to
you about the Justice League oh my you
got the worst timing in the world man
hey guys so once again this is my fiance
Sam and we're going to talk about man
steel a little bit but I just want to
make sure if you didn't read the title
all the way this is a spoiler review
100% spoilers everywhere so stay away if
you haven't seen the movie yet I have a
spoiler free review up already that you
can go check out check that one out
first before you watch this one
so as we promised at the end of our Iron
Man 3 spoiler review we were gonna come
back and do our spoiler thoughts on Man
of Steel and you went to the drive-in
last night and checked it out I saw it
for the second time she saw for the
first time they know how I feel about it
so what are your overall thoughts on the
on the film well it was okay it wasn't
spectacular but it wasn't okay with him
I didn't mind it but it's not something
I'm gonna go actively try to pursue to
watch again like I did with Iron Man the
first time I saw it I was I was a little
letdown because I wanted it to be like
the perfect film that the trailers made
it look like it was going to be and that
was a little stupid of me to go in
expecting like perfection because you
know I mean I need to learn to not hype
myself because that's that's gonna make
experiences not as fun for me
nevertheless I did enjoy the film I
thought it was a well made film and if
you followed the Superman films from
1978 all the way to Superman Returns I
really do think yes issues you've seen
Superman Returns yeah okay see I really
do think that that this Superman was
good for for what Superman needed this
film didn't have any emotional depth it
was just all bomb there was quite a bit
of action in the movie and it's funny
well action I think it was half the
movies explosions on sorry it was pretty
much all the epic scenes that went high
peak high peak high peak one little low
peak where it showed his past a little
blurb with his parent father thing and
it was pretty much no actual time to
digest those action scenes you saw or
have any like emotional attachment to
the characters it's just like I feel
like I don't even know Lois Lane I don't
know Clark Kent
I don't know Perry White I don't know
any of the characters that they just
presented to me my two biggest problems
in the movie were the structural
integrity of the movie it felt so huge
and big without enough downtime to
really digest and to you know feel like
you had some emotional depth in there
and my other problem was you didn't
really feel that close to Superman as a
person I thought his youth was really
well told like with Kevin Costner as
John
and Kenneth oh he did such a good job
and Russell broke those scenes were very
actually well done and very well
executed with a lot of thought and
detail put into their back history and
those very very brief short blurs that
they put in one problem I also had that
I know that you agreed with was I felt
the romance between
Lois Lane and Superman was like
instantaneous and barely developed at
all I get that when he saved her in the
ice sculpture and then cauterized her
wound that obviously she would be
intrigued by that like anyone would be
like I must find out who this is
Superman Returns didn't have enough
action and it had a lot of drama and
emotion in there but Manish steel had a
ton of action which Superman needed but
it didn't have really that pole that you
wanted from like you thought we were
maybe going to get with Superman so I
feel like maybe if they combine the best
and worst aspects of both of those
movies they would have been like a
perfect Superman movie I still really
enjoyed it though like I don't you guys
take that no no I don't want you guys to
get us wrong like we don't hate the move
we don't even dislike the movie it just
could have been better definitely
definitely not like I hate I mean I hate
the director of this like I want to go
with you with the movie that should not
be mentioned ever in existence by
Dragonball Evolution yes okay yeah see
Dragonball Evolution it's a curse word
my household so let's not say that again
exactly I did like how they strayed away
from the whole let's make Lois Lane not
know who Clark as soon as he puts on a
pair of glasses and puts a twirl in his
hair I mean I love the way to open up
Russell Crowe on Krypton I thought that
was a really great the whole that was
actually was really do like it
it gave me high hopes for the rest of
the film first opening sequence would
probably I'm gonna go with an a-plus for
that Krypton think that's an a-plus film
and then from there kinda just went down
letter grades dropped the thing and then
it hit back up kind of at the end when
they left it off a pretty good spot yeah
see I went back and I watched The Dark
Knight last night just for fun and I was
like oh it's just such a good movie oh
my god that's such a good movie and I'm
not comparing it
I know Nolan was involved on the story
aspect of Man of Steel and I think that
the story that he provided and helped
shape for this Superman tale was about
as realistic as a story as you can
portray with this guy and having
have it be like taken seriously
obviously after coming off of something
like Batman you're gonna have to turn it
more human adaptation to it there's like
that one great monologue at the end
where he's like what before they start
fighting he's like you I have no people
I have nothing and then he's like and
now I'm going to kill you raw Dragon
Ball Z yeah Henry Cavill did a pretty
good job in the movie I'm not saying he
wasn't a bad Superman oh no no spit I'm
thinking with the store that they gave
him and the script that they gave him
that he did what he could with it and
the adapt that his adaptation and was
very good no Superman more a little more
grunged up like they did with the Dark
Knight one of the things that I was sort
of looking forward to in this movie but
wasn't sure if they were gonna do was
any hints at all to the Justice League
and the only thing that I could find
they had one little tiny little thing
that has nothing really do with the
Justice League actually my buddy Jon
flicking jerk told this to me on the
phone I was like I better looked at a
second time and I was looking for our
way through the whole thing on a
satellite you can see an upside down
logo for Wayne Enterprises in space and
I was like oh well that's really it we
don't get after credit scene we don't
get a Justice League reference a friend
of mine named Craig he runs a website
called fat movie guy he is pretty funny
title after the movie he was like they
can't teach something it doesn't exist
there's no official Justice League movie
in the world it's officially in the
works but every script keeps getting
like turned down so they can't really
teach something doesn't exist the most
epic thing that could have ever happened
that would literally make me faint in
the theater as if Christian Bale dressed
as Batman just came in was like hell
okay talk about Justice League but
Christian Bale is done and the nolan
films don't connect to these my thoughts
unlike the end fight I thought the anta
fire was really awesome because look I'm
a fanboy nerd for comics as you are too
except your referral
I mean look behind me I got all the
Superman stuff I wanted to see Superman
kick ass because we haven't seen that
since Superman for the quest for peace
which is a horrible movie and the fight
scene is it's not gonna fight scene they
just kind of slow dance around in slow
motion for a while so I wanted to see a
kick-ass Superman and I got that it was
the Superman movie that I think the
public needed to see because Superman
Returns was a very dull movie and we
needed a movie that could show that
Superman has a villain besides Lex
Luthor and there are other people that
he can actually
engage in battle with and I really like
that part of the movie like when they
threatened Diane Lane his mother and he
just like boom just runs rushes in there
grabs on he's like you could throw at my
mother I was like that's probably the
best son you could possibly have um I
wondered if you had thank you um can you
infer this very said you knew I was
talking I know I I know you one of my
favorite scenes is probably when they're
in the Kryptonian ship and Lois is
trying to figure out how to get out of
there and jor-el shows up it is slinging
to her how to get out of there
that was awesome I'm like they actually
like made low is kind of a little bit
more involved versus her being just the
damsel in distress that Superman's got a
rescue right I mean it hadn't cliched
her falling from great height and
Superman having to catch her but she got
I have it's surprisingly people Superman
catches people one of the things that I
did like about that also I love Russell
Crowe just in the background going poop
and like opening and closing the doors
before don't come in there open there's
a guy right there there's a guy right
there and then like every room he
everyone she walked in he would just
feel like going like this go that way
who's like the best directions you could
possibly have can you imagine having a
Russell Crowe GPS present in your car
dear fool are you just getting your car
and he's like drive to Arby's this way
and then he's like by the way Arby's is
bad for you you shouldn't eat Arby's hit
Chipotle instead yeah I thought the two
father figures of Clark was actually
we're actually my favorite performances
in the movie actually Kevin Costner and
Russel Crowe they were very balancing of
how he is you can also see that he
definitely had a lot of influences from
his mother being more in his life yeah
things oh he's a mama's boy
you can tell he's a mama's boy and
that's like he comes in hugs her
he's like nice suit son impenetrable
never will rip soup so you don't have to
see an Akey Superman pushing my version
yeah yeah he knows me too well thank
goodness I don't have to see that though
can you imagine that rated-r Superman
running around with this giant super
dick okay um I really like that Superman
had to go to the one that was in like
around the Indian Ocean and likes fly up
through it that was a really epic scene
I thought how we had to like fight the
gravity that was pretty cool I like that
a lot
the sound though that drove me insane
like I realize for you she has a little
bit of a here it's you yeah overall I
think we both agree that it was an
entertaining summer popcorn film it was
a good Superman movie but that it just
didn't have the emotional core we were
hoping for and we both kind of felt that
the central romance wasn't really
explored enough at all like even it just
kind of happened so fast and action good
emotion good emitter yeah overall I will
stick by my b-plus Man of Steel grade I
could see someone giving it a beat I'm
gonna give it a low B okay see that's
fair to me I'm excited to see to you to
see what they do with it to see if they
can maybe connect the two films into
having to need the wand to make two more
understandable maybe they're gonna play
that card right that he needs the
balancing act to game there right so the
next big comic book film is Wolverine I
guess you want to see that with me we
can do a spoiler video that - cool hmm
I'm excited to see will Vereen yeah he's
jealous we'll go see Wolverine oh I love
you Jackman he's awesome you can looking
at my own guy look at him too hahahaha
least you admitted any scene with he's a
good-looking guy good-looking so we'll
come back and do a Wolverine spoiler
review we won't when you get a geeky
girlfriend slash fiance you're gonna end
up it's a plus
it's the incorporation of lifestyle into
work yeah it more enjoyable that's true
for all parties involved that's true
thanks a lot for watching guys we
appreciate it and I will see you very
soon and I have to say it alright guys
hopefully give him back to his channel
and hopefully you get stuck man eyes off
this you made it seem like it was a drug
I got stuck mine eyes off that oh I got
the high off that leave me guys this is
a drug that you might get addicted to
maybe okay
oh thank you SEC officers thank you very
much I appreciate that
well now the fat man's gone mr. Kent
let's go work on that report you guys
know I'm still here right